this business on mersey island has been
growing and harvesting oysters for five
generations
keep them healthy and our safe oysters
need clean pollution-free water
though a sewage spill has never affected
this business directly the owner has
joined a legal action against the
government fearing it's only a matter of
time and if you're pumping surge into
the sea those oysters will take it
contaminate them
shut us down or even make someone really
ill and God forbid that could ever
happen so it's just something that 300
years of us growing oysters as a family
that we've been doing it for sewage
could stop that Legacy in an instance
since 2020 England's water firms pumped
sewage into our rivers and seas for more
than seven million hours the latest data
shows not much has changed
England's 10 water and sewage companies
monitored just over 300 000 sewage spill
events in 2022
this is down around 19 on 2021 but is
largely due to below average rainfall
rather than interventions made by the
industry
the highest number of spills were
recorded by United utilities which
serves the northwest of the country it
monitored almost 70 000 sewage spells
last year essentially what those figures
mean is there's sewage going to our
Rivers pretty much all the time this
this charge in Essex has been going on
for about the last 40 hours I can I can
smell the sewage running into this
stream in response to these latest
figures water UK which represents water
companies said it was bringing Ford 56
billion of Investments to help bring
about the transformation that we all
want to see the thing is that
transformation isn't going to happen
very quickly
the government doesn't require water
companies to improve storm overflows
into bathing water sites until 2035 and
remaining overflows until 2050.
Tom Howard is hoping a case coming
before the high court later this year
bought by him and two campaign groups
will force the government to do more
government just need to have some guts
and say look this isn't good enough and
they need to be forced to have some
teeth and stand up towards companies and
say we need to do more and admit they
need to do more
Howard's great great grandfather was
running this business when the
victorians built most of our sewers they
factored in some population growth but
not subsequent Decades of under
investment by water firms now the
pressure is on to make good on their
inheritance Tom Clark Sky News Essex